hey how are you how are you have a
driver's license registration appr
insurance with you I'm
sorry oh yeah if you got yours
sure I'm
sorry thank
you I'm sorry like I don't get pulled
over I don't know where my
insurance
registration I have
yours what do you have a ticket for
there you're holding a ticket in your
hand is that yours yeah I hate this I
just haven't clean my car don't judge me
okay where are you guys coming from
today don don
yeah all right how much does you have to
drink
today I I
have I can show you if you want you're
the passenger in the vehicle so I'm not
too concerned I'm concerned with yeah
have you had anything to drink today any
illegal drugs
any just alcohol yes I had two drinks
two drinks okay how's your license what
how's your license are you suspended
anything like that oh no no all right
give me a favor turn the key off and
just throw the keys up on the dashboard
for me all right I'm going to go double
check your license and I'll be right
back with you all right Karina step out
of the car
for why cuz I want to talk to you on the
side of the road probably
get I can drive home what do you mean
I'm not I didn't drink anything all
right that's fine but I can take a test
I I could do anything you want I I just
have I
only the only issue I have is the reason
why I'm stopping you guys in the first
place is when you were coming over the
bridge I noticed that you guys were
failing to maintain your lane um I saw
you guys laughing and joking so but as I
continue to follow you guys down the
hot I know
my dri we'll cross that bridge when we
get there
the other issue the other issue is you
handed me a driver's license that says
you are not 21 until next year 24 years
old so no you're the driver did no I'm
24 you so right now I'm asking you to
step out of the vehicle so we can talk
on the side of the road step out of the
vehicle yes I believe you're
intoxicated listen I
mean I mean it's fine
all right what we're going to do is
we're going to step on the side of the
road we're going to have a chat and
we're going to go from there all
right how long ago did you guys leave
Donovan 30 minutes ago 30 minutes ago
how much did you really have to
drink the fish are on to you really got
really got it
all right they got
me
so like I said I stopped you cuz the
whole way down the highway you're not
maintaining your lane ma'am stay in the
car ma'am stay in the car stay in the
car stay in Miss get in the
car I'm sorry guys I'm new to this I'm
like way to that's all right
um do you have I dig yes of course
I mean I'm on medication right now I I
just need to see your right day I just I
that's why I didn't
drive hold on Danny I'm trying to find
my fucking relax I just keep can you
hang up the phone yeah actually it's my
boyfriend I'm going put him on speaker
if you don't want no if you can hang up
the phone I'm going to put it on speaker
thank
you all right we're going to get back to
this body cam in a second but I want to
take a minute to talk about something
else that happens all the time work
Place injuries if you get hurt at your
job whether it's a slip and fall a
mechanical failure negligence of your
co-workers something hits you you're
going to need a trusted law firm in your
corner enter Pon Le hockey Giordano a
firm that is a heavyweight in the
industry that wins all different kinds
of injury cases yes workplace but also
accidents Social Security Disability
injuries they have a track record of
recovering over $1 billion for their
clients and they have won over a 100,000
cases they have 250 years of combined
experience how amazing is that so you
can check out Pon Le hockey gordano at
Pon leeh hockey.com
ELC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833
66944 I or let's get back to the body
zny I can't find
my it should be in your wallet I know it
should be I have my debit card I have my
credit card I have my credit karma card
I just had
my I know I I literally I is this
vehicle in your name ma'am no this is
not my car this is not my vehicle I am
I'm on medication which why I didn't
drive I'm
over you're not in any trouble I know I
can drive I I have you're where myid
okay ma'am you're not in any trouble no
I don't care if I'm in trouble I just I
just want you to know I have my ID what
what just out of curiosity what actually
you
know so I can drive if she is drunk but
I just am in pain you're not in any
trouble I just need to see yeah just
when you get a chance that's it you um
do you remember the last time I
li
yeah that's
fine just stand over
here here yep right there
perfect do you have a shirt that you
want to put on oh I
guess hang on don't no just is it is it
that pink one that's a dress okay can
you just all right wait do
hang on no stand stand back over there
let's see if we can get you a shirt just
way you're not cold why don't you yeah
put the put the sweatshirt on ins it's
all
right I'm like God damn I got to put
myself together I'm like
outside I'm sorry
okay all
right do you have any issues with your
legs do you have any medical conditions
that affect your balance any injuries
any back injuries
but I hope
not have you been injured I don't know
I've been taking
medications I mean like blood work I
don't think anything with my legs other
than like my knees and my
join I don't know that's perfectly fine
okay so what I want you to do I get it
all right get one
right is that
like
oh my God
maybe you know what I remember j class
like
said okay Miss what's your name
Karina Karina Karina Karina yeah I want
you I want you to pay attention very
closely to what he's telling you to do
okay and I want you I want you to do
only that so I want you I want you to
look okay so this is what he said right
so you're going to stand here with your
feet together like this toes pointed
forward you see where my you see how my
hands are you see how they're down by my
side I want you to keep your hands at
your side touching touching the sides of
your legs all right then you're going to
extend your foot you're going to extend
your foot straight out in front of you
keeping your foot parallel to the ground
explainer I'm Sor okay that's okay so I
want you just I just want you to watch
what I'm doing okay I don't want you to
do it yet all right you're going to
stand with your foot parallel to the
ground ma'am just stay in the car okay
I'm sorry I'm I'm looking
that's okay that's okay it's it's fine
all right ma'am just stay in your car
okay just just stay in the
car okay all right it's okay so just
we're just gonna get back to
this all right so this is what I this is
what I yeah I don't want you to do it
yet I don't want you to do it yet okay I
don't don't start yet so just put your
foot down at your side okay you're going
to stand like this you're going to have
your hands down to your side like this
you're going to extend your leg in front
of you don't do it yet just listen to me
all right you're going to send your leg
in front of you you're going to keep
your foot parallel to the ground you're
going to keep your eye on your foot as
you're doing this you're going to count
Out Loud by 1000 so 1,001 1,002
1,3 so on and so forth until I tell you
to stop that's aw if wait wait it's not
yet not yet all right so if anytime you
drop your foot so if let's say 1,1 1,002
13 if you drop your foot you're going to
pick it back up and start from where you
left off so for example 1 1000 do I have
to get wait wait wait listen to me so 1
1000 2 1,000 3 1,000 drop it pick it
back up 4 1,000 5 1,000 6 1000 and
you're going to keep going until we tell
you to stop oh okay all right 10000
10000 that's right though I got to make
sure I pass it no that's okay do you
have any do you have any other questions
though 1 1 2 1000 that right yep like
that but you're going to keep your arms
down at your side touching your side
extend it out in front of you put
parallel to the ground I'm sorry I'm so
let's start from the beginning all right
so I want you to start from the starting
position ma'am I need you to ma'am ma'am
I need you to come to the back of the
car ma'am I need you to stay in the car
we we are on a highway no I need you to
stay in the car we're on a highway okay
Miss come
on oh my God
sorry so from here Sor do you have any
questions about that test all right
remember arms at your side down your
side foot extended in front of you foot
parel to the ground when I tell you to
begin okay all right I'm
ready okay you may
begin
all right thean elvator is going to
conduct another test with you okay all
right stay standing where you
were all right for the next test what I
want you to do place your left foot out
in front of you place your right foot
touching Heel To Toe in front of your
left foot stay in that position while I
explain the next test you're going to
imagine a line just crack in the roadway
all that crack in the roadway all right
you're going to take a series of nine
steps touching Heel To Toe on each step
just if you get back to the starting
position
your right foot on this
TR left touching heel to to yeah keep
your hands down at your side stay in
that position while I finished
explaining this all right yes so taking
a series of nine steps directly out in
front of you you're going to upon
completion of the nine step we're going
to use a series of short chopping steps
turn around wait what I'm going let me
you're going takes n steps returning
beginning
right so so I'm going to do it I'm going
to do it this way so you can see all
right oh you're I'm going to do it for
me so watch thank you when I tell you to
start just do me a favor get back in the
starting
position remember the starting position
for this one right we're heel the toe
put our hands down at our sides like
this okay gosh so when I instruct you to
you're going to start again I'm going to
take three steps you're going to take
all right you go one two three time
three I'm doing three you're doing nine
you're going to turn around you're going
to go back one two three until you get
to nine all right on each step I want
you to make sure that you oh so you want
me going nine n steps out nine steps
back that's it
right just during the test make sure you
touch heel the toe and you keep Miss I
need you to stay in the car no I am
there's somebody coming okay for me all
right just I am going to stay in the car
okay just stay in the car okay that's
fine I'm sorry that's fine just stay in
the car can I hold my hand out the
window is that okay yeah let's just
close the car door okay you can stay
with the window
open did you understand the
instructions
so I want to make sure you understand
them okay so you're going to yep you're
going to use you're going to so let's go
back to the beginning all right just
listen take a deep breath all right I'm
going explain this to you one more time
all right try to go slow just so that
there's no confusions all right I need
to do is just pay
attention feel like you're may your
attention may be divided this is very
okay right so again stay in the starting
position left fo Down Right Foot In
Front touching heel to Y so you see you
see the straight line in front of you
like The Faded one yep you're going to
use that as a guide you're going to walk
directly on that line okay so you have
your left foot on that line your right
foot directly in front of your left
foot I would we're not even just need to
listen so I want you to focus on this
nothing else I want you to focus on what
I'm telling you keep your arms down at
your side okay stay in this position
until I tell you to start okay from here
you're going to take a series of nine
steps Heel To Toe
counting let me finish nine steps Heel
To Toe counting out loud looking down at
your feet while you're taking taking
these steps keeping your hands down at
your side at the end of your ninth step
you're going to take a series of small
steps turning around and you're going to
take another nine steps back to where
you begin counting out loud so it'll
look like this right so one know I had
to I'm sorry three I took three you're
going to take nine that's why that's why
we want to make sure you understand just
let me finish right we're going to take
series of small steps turning around and
again one two three so it should look
just like that do you have any questions
y yep your feet like that your arms at
your side Miss just stay in the car I
just want to witness it okay no you have
to stay in the car no I want to witness
it I'm so sorry but I'm hearing what
you're saying and I need to witness the
do you do you realize that by
interfering with motor vehicle stop and
also arrest you for obstruction so
please get back you want to me I really
don't I want get into I just want to see
what going I need you to get into the
vehicle I'm in pain I can't sit can I
stand can I I need you to get into the
vehicle I need you to get
into there so five minutes away I need
you to get into the vehicle Miss I need
you to get into the vehicle and stay in
the vehicle Miss I need you to get into
the vehicle and stay in the vehicle I
need
you I need you to get into the vehicle
and stay in the vehicle we are on a
highway understand okay I need you to
please get into the vehicle I'm not I'm
not trying to you I'm not miss I'm not
listen what's your name tell you again
please get into the vehicle Miss I
respect you please get into the vehicle
please get into the vehicle stay into
the vehicle do not leave the vehicle
until we tell you to leave the vehicle
do you understand that okay I have to
finish what she's doing and then I will
come back and talk to you I promise I'm
sorry all right do you have any
questions about what we talked
about 1000 like that okay I'm going to
explain and demonstrate this test one
more time no no no no you not I'm not
that St
I okay all right what's your name
understand what's your name Olivia Maro
okay and you my boyfriend is right
here I need you to take some deep
breaths it's about
you you need to stay in the vehicle we
are on a very busy highway even when
your boyfriend gets here you cannot
leave
until I tell you you can leave this
vehicle understand okay please stay in
the please stay in the vehicle during
each step I want you to clch heel the
toe and count out loud okay I'm going to
demonstrate it again I'm going to do
three steps just for time sake and
you're going to do
nine all right so one two three you're
going to turn
around you go one
two three just remember to count each
step alow okay do you understand those
instructions that way n
[Music]
correct
loation phone
calls been hared or an app in other apps
no phone
calls
okay Karina what's your highest level of
Education I'm a sophomore in college
okay so it's fair to to say that you
know the English alphabet from A to Z
correct do you know do you know the
alphabet yeah all right this
is do me a favor stand once again Fe
feet together hands at your side all
right I know I know
I miss
miss this is my mom's
car here but listen I don't care no Miss
I'm in pain I to stand up Miss I'm in
pain Miss I understand I'm not trying to
disrespect you turn off I'm in I'm in a
lot calm down you cannot just run out of
a vehicle on a motor vehicle stop until
we allow you to
go
I will stand where you want me to but I
need to stand up listen I cannot sit I
cannot sit if you're not listening I'm a
I need to stand so tell me where to
stand I will stand wherever you want me
to but I cannot sit in that
car I will stand there I will stand
there I will stand anywhere please
please let me S anywhere you need to
understand I understand saying no you
have not cuz you have not listened to a
thing I have said I will so if we go
back to the car once you're free to
leave I will allow you to leave with
your boyfriend okay but you cannot just
run out of a vehicle when you were on a
motor vehicle CL sorry but can I please
can you let me stand okay please you
need to listen to me I will listen to
you but keep pleas don't stand up that's
all I'm asking I don't need to I will
sit I will stand by the car I just need
to
can't I need you to stop talking okay
okay I'm going to let you take her
because I'm afraid that she's going to
next run across the
highway understand I but that's why I'm
nervous because she has not listened to
anything that we have said this entire
time and she's been veryit okay I want
her to be safe I want her to get out of
here I think she does still have
belongings in that car I cannot let you
take those until we're done with what
we're doing so if you want to hang out
hang right here okay that's fine
but she can't she's not going to be if
she gets into thisle she wants doctor
notes I will give it to her you either
need to get into the get back into that
vehicle so let me get my belonging you
need to get into this vehicle or you
need to get into that vehicle but those
are your two options you cannot stand
outside the car am I being arrested am I
being arrested if you keep interfering I
can't arrest you I don't want to do that
so please get into the can I not get my
belongings get into the vehicle and we
will get your belongings for you I
cannot have you run back and forth
across this
highway I'm going to I am going to
arrest you you don't get into this car
no no get in the car listen to your
boyfriend and get into the car you're
going to get it we're going to get it
just sit
[Applause]
down lock the doors please keep in
there
[Music]
Dro
off CLE that
out 1 count need a toe for
John
[Applause]
[Music]
do you have anything in your car that
you're going to need cell phone wallet
all right we'll grab some stuff for you
I'm not okay with at all
okay do you have a cell phone in here
that you
need so what
exactly are you guys doing like you're
being placed under arrest for driving
while intoxicated okay do you have a
cell phone in here or anything that you
need mhm I'm Sor okay we'll grab it for
you I don't I do
not okay all right I'll I'll look for it
and I'll I'll grab it I'll get it for
you okay you
yeah or the black oh my
God I cannot believe that all right
let's go back
here
ridiculous